almost all American journalism is
controlled by a few massive corporations
news voice is a one-of-a-kind mobile app
that tracks the bias and corporate
interests that infuse the news stories
we consume every day and it's completely
free to use go to news voice dot-com
slash Pakman to download it so three and
a half weeks ago I did a story for you
guys called doctor foul Qi has been
disappeared from Trump's briefings that
was nearly a full months ago and at the
time we were seeing signals of what was
to come get the doctors the hell out of
the way stop talking about death stop
talking about masks and people doing the
stuff that they need to do simply start
talking about reopening and this is when
I told you back of three and a half
weeks ago that Trump was no longer going
to have doctors at briefings he would be
15 away from daily medical briefings
where media get to talk to doctors like
dr. fowey and doctor Bert's they're just
going to talk about the economy it's
gonna be like the disease is over they
are going to normalize the coronavirus
deaths not only did that happen
dr. pouchy has been disappeared from any
interviews on television as well he has
not been seen since I believe it was May
fourth there was a while where doctor
foul Chi was pulled off of Trump's
briefings but he was still doing regular
television interviews no more pouchy has
been conspicuously absent from TV for
more than two weeks now it is completely
utterly obviously clear that this is
part of a concerted effort to make it
seem like the virus part of the pandemic
is over now of course you know this
isn't true we fortunately started to see
sort of a slow decline in new cases and
that's of course very good deaths have
been kind of up and down if you look at
a moving average as we call it they've
also been on a decline that's all really
really good news but this is still a
pandemic we still have no effective
treatment
we are still months from a vaccine we
are still shut down in a significant
portion of state economies but the
doctors are gone you just don't see them
anymore doc
ouchies last TV interview again I
believe was May fourth that's two and a
half weeks ago he's been missing since
and I need you to understand that this
is not a coincidence he is missing not
because nobody wants to interview him
anymore
Media want to talk to dr. Fuji he's been
pulled now some of you might wonder
wasn't voci on a modified quarantine
after he was exposed to people at the
White House who tested positive for
coronavirus that shouldn't stop him from
doing interviews doctor foul he was
regularly doing interviews by
videoconference before he testified
before the Senate via videoconference
that is not the reason why dr. fowey is
no longer on TV if there was ever a week
to have dr. Fauci on TV it would be did
this week good results from a vaccine
trial he works for the NIH which is
working in partnership with these
private industry private companies
developing a corona virus vaccine this
is just short of North Korean style
propaganda we've got a 100-year global
pandemic that's ravaging the economy our
economy in the global economy obviously
you put fast-food CEOs on TV instead of
an infectious disease doctor and the
other night on CNN they said we are no
longer going to be allowed to interview
dr. Fauci and dr. Burks the White House
is no longer allowing them to do
interviews on CNN anymore now you could
say well CNN is fake news obviously
they're not going to be fair well
they're not being allowed to do
interviews anywhere and this is such a
common technique it's called hide the
facts there's an article from earlier
this month in The Guardian from
economist Robert Reich and he wrote
about Trump's four-step plan to reopen
the United States and the four steps are
start removing income support so people
have no choice but to return to work one
twelve hundred dollar check unclear that
there's going to be another check at
this point in time check they're doing
it number two
hide the facts and that's what we're
talking about today that's where doctor
foul chief it's in this is where Florida
not releasing cause of death fits in
hide the facts number three pretend that
it's all about freedom and you
patriotism and liberty they're doing
that and then number four Robert rice
wrote about this nearly a month ago
shield businesses from lawsuits for
spreading the infection by opening too
early all week Donald Trump has been
talking about how he wants to see that
made a reality we're a backwards country
we need to be hearing more from doctors
not less we do not need to be hearing
from fast-food CEOs Trump did I covered
it live and I it was disgusting
Trump did a whole roundtable earlier
this week with restaurant people and
they also found a psychiatrist willing
to say we've got to reopen the economy
now that that's an entire other story
they have now been looking for random
doctors willing to say my medical
opinion is we should open or open her up
and let it rip they did find one earlier
this week but they're hiding the truths
the truth they are hiding dr. fowey and
instead they're bringing you know the
the CEO of a chicken joint to talk about
how important it is that we get back
open it is ugly and it is bordering on
the type of propaganda that typically we
see from totalitarian countries places
where you have a real authoritarian
Trump's a wannabe authoritarian he is
very quickly becoming a real one that
includes hiding the facts here later on
we will talk about Donald Trump's
threats to States over vote-by-mail
plans really really ugly dangerous stuff
we'll continue covering this and other
stories from today's program on the
David Pakman show Instagram follow us at
david pakman show on Instagram and
follow me at David Pakman don't forget
about little old me